aquí tenemos esta figura de apariencia
extraña para la cual nos piden que
calculemos su área aunque tiene una
apariencia extraña nos dan algunas
medidas este lado mide 3.5 este de acá
6.5 este cachito mide 2 este cachito
mide 7 y finalmente esta altura mide 3.5
a partir de esta información nos
gustaría determinar el área así que te
recomiendo que detengas el vídeo e
intentes este problema por tu cuenta
yo voy a empezar ahorita a hacer la
solución bueno en efecto esta figura
tiene apariencia extraña y no tenemos
una fórmula específica para que nos dé
su área sin embargo lo que podemos hacer
es dividir esta figura en figuras más
pequeñas y calcular el área de todas
ellas y después sumar hay dos figuras
que salen así inmediatamente que son
estos dos triángulos este de la
izquierda este de acá y este de la
derecha vamos a empezar calculando sus
áreas para calcular el área de este
triángulo recordemos los siguientes
recordemos que si tuvieran
un rectángulo de base 2 y de altura 3.5
entonces su área sería multiplicar 2 por
3.5 2 por 3.5 pero si queremos el área
del triángulo del triángulo de base 2 y
altura 3.5 hay que multiplicar por un
medio porque estamos considerando este
triángulo y hay 2 de esos en un
rectángulo sale bueno entonces aquí
sería un medio por 2 que es 1 y luego 1
por 3.5 es 3.5 entonces el área de este
triángulo sería de 3.5 unidades
cuadradas vale bueno vamos a hacer lo
mismo con este triángulo de acá para
encontrar el área tenemos que
multiplicar un medio de su base que es 7
x la altura por 3.5 un medio de 7 es 3.5
entonces nos queda 3.5 por 3.5 vamos a
hacer esta multiplicación por acá
3.5 por 3.5 a ver 5 por 5 es 25 y
llevamos 25 por 13 15 y 2 que llevamos
17 va este 2 lo tachamos aquí va un 0
pasamos al 33 por 5 es 15 y llevamos 13
por 39 y una que llevamos es 10 muy bien
vamos a sumar 5 0 5 7 y 5 es 12 llevamos
una una yúnes 2 aquí va un 1 ok y aquí a
ver recorrimos el punto decimal un lugar
aquí un lugar entonces aquí se recorre
dos lugares sale entonces el área de
este triangulito sería de 12 12.25 muy
bien ahora lo que nos falta es este
trapecio de acá que también se puede ver
un poco intimidante sin embargo es muy
sencillo calcular el área de un trapecio
una vez que nos damos cuenta de que está
formado por un rectángulo por un
rectángulo y un triángulo rectángulo
aquí es ángulo recto ángulo recto y aquí
además conocemos los lados conocemos el
largo que sería de 2 + 7 o sea de 9 y
conocemos el alto que es de 3.5 3.5 y de
hecho si esto me de 3.5 para que en
total mida 6.5 esto de acá debe de medir
3 sale este cachito entonces con esto ya
conocemos todos conocemos la base y la
altura tanto del rectángulo como del
triángulo vamos a calcular sus áreas
la de este rectángulo sería multiplicar
9 por 3.5 esto lo podemos hacer
mentalmente verdad es lo mismo que 9 por
39 por punto 5 por la propiedad
distributiva 9 por 13 27 ya eso tenemos
que sumarle 9 por punto 5 o sea la mitad
de 9 más 4.5 27 4 es 31.5 es 31 31.5
deja miren cerrando las áreas para que
no se me pierdan
esta de acá y estaría acá y finalmente
el área de este triángulo se calcularía
como un medio multiplicado por la base
multiplicado por la altura que sería 9
esto cuánto estrés por 9 es 27 27 entre
12 es igual a 13.5 entonces el área
sería de 13.5 muy bien 13 puntos 5
unidades cuadradas así que para
encontrar el área de esta región rosa
basta sumar estas cuatro áreas que
encontramos sería 13.5 13.5 + 31.5
+ 3.5 3.5 más 12.25 vamos a realizar
esta suma
aquí el 5 baja no pasa nada 5 y 5 es 10
y 5 es 15 y 23 17
llevamos una una y 3 4 y 15 y 13 18
y 13 18 y 38 y 12 10 10 y llevamos 11 y
12 y 13 5 y una es 6 de esta forma el
área de toda esta región rosa es de 60
puntos 75 unidades cuadradas